hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in Aristotle's work the Poetics he tells
us that character is among the most
important parts or elements there's six
of them of tragedy as a whole and we can
say that it's among the most because it
is not the most important part According
to Aristotle we actually have do have
tragedies though not good ones which are
lacking character it is the second most
important behind plot or story muthos
right character is ethos and this is a
term that Aristotle uses in many other
places it's an incredibly important in
the nick of McCann ethics where you know
it's all about how we develop our
characters for Better or For Worse
but it also plays a role in the politics
uh important means of persuasion in the
rhetoric so this is something that is
tied in with a lot of other discussions
now we're interested primarily in what
Aristotle is telling us here in the
Poetics about character and tragedy in
particular
so why is it this second most important
part so he's going to tell us three big
things almost like you know in
succession and the first thing is a
definition you might say because he's
actually going to say at the end of this
section that he has defined the
different parts of it so he says
character is that in virtue of which or
by which pothole right in accordance
with which you could actually say we
ascribe
agents uh certain qualities right we say
that they are of this sort uh poyon this
is actually one of Aristotle's
categories uh in that work the
categories and discussed in many other
things so you know what are examples of
this well when we ascribe goodness or
Badness in general to a person we're
saying that they have a certain quality
right that substance the human being has
this very important Central quality
which they could you know they could
lose uh when we ascribe virtues or vices
by saying that somebody is courageous or
cowardly we are likewise saying what
kind of person they are and this extends
not just to the actions or the habits
but also to structures of motivation
which are revealed in what Aristotle
calls thought but also in action so
that's one really important point right
off the character is about qualities
that a person is said to have it could
be wrong right oftentimes we find in
plays that we think somebody's a villain
and they turn out not to be so or you
know vice versa
the second thing that he's going to tell
us
has to do with the connection between
qualities and actions and happiness
so he's going to connect together
the plot and the characters that are
involved and I should mention too by the
way that Aristotle doesn't always talk
about character in the singular he very
often is referencing it in the plural
characters play a role the different
characters of the different people in
the play so here's what he he says the
most important of these different
elements is the structure of events that
is plot why because tragedy is mimesis
not of persons but of action in life and
happiness and unhappiness consistent
action the goal is a certain kind of
action not a qualitative State and then
he says it is in virtue of character
it's because of their character that
people have these particular qualities
but it is through their actions that
they are happy or the the reverse
otherwise you know the opposite of this
now happiness here is eudaimonial so you
know some sometimes people don't want to
call that happiness they want to call it
flourishing it doesn't really matter
right a good state is the product of the
actions that you engage in and likewise
a bad State and the actions do flow from
the character that you have you not only
display it in the actions but it's also
what is driving the actions now coming
back to this
um
tragedy is imitation or mimesis of
action of actions praxes the things that
we do and of Life of our overall
structure of our life is our life a
successful one or a dismal one well that
can make us happy uh or unhappy and he
actually uses the word Coco daimonia
which is the opposite of eudaimonia
right you is well cacos is bad right so
we can have uh you know bad life and
we're looking at some sort of goal or
Telos the goal he says is a certain kind
of action an action that displays
character not just
being of a you know certain quality but
something a bit deeper so that's
getting to some interesting things and
then finally he tells us uh just a
little bit later after this
character is what reveals uh day Loy to
unveil to show us right moral choice
provide racist this is an incredibly
important term for Aristotle you can't
quite translate it as will but think of
it as the the enduring complex of your
choices and commitments over time and
your acts of choosing things or
prioritizing things or making
commitments so you're prior racist is
really at the core of who you are as a
matter of fact in the nick of McCann
ethics Aristotle situates it as sort of
the bridge between our intellectual
parts and our affective or emotional or
desirous parts he calls it
um you know two different terms that are
basically reversing it mind that has
desire or desire that is you know
intellect sure those are kind of rough
translations but priorases is incredibly
important that is at the core of a
character
and so we have different kinds of
priorities good ones bad ones ones in
the middle
and he tells us that it reveals uh what
when otherwise unclear right so when
we're not quite sure about people
what kind of things an agent chooses or
prioritizes proirite that's the same
term just turned into a verb or reject
literally runs away from fugay flees
right and this is part of what makes us
who we are right so this is uh quite
important now a bit later on in the text
he's going to tell us something a bit
more normative about how characters
ought to be constructed and portrayed
within tragedies now now he doesn't mean
every single person obviously because we
do have bad people in tragedy so the
very first the very first
Criterion that he gives us would be
ruled out by that but he is talking
about at least some of the characters
need to have this and he says first and
foremost that they're actually good
stop so this is a term that can mean
good or beneficial or useful here I
think Aristotle is actually using it in
this wider sense not to mean you know
the Paragon of goodness but you know
decent is a way we could translate it
and he goes on and he says that
characterization appears when as we said
earlier in these other things speecher
action reveals the nature of a moral
choice and it's good character that's
being displayed when the choice is good
now how do we know what choices people
are making partly by what they do and
partly by what they say about it the
characters in the play will say I am
doing this because of this that's what
aerosolicus fought right but it also
displays moral choice
the second thing that he says is that uh
characters need to be
appropriate right they need to quite
literally harmonize
right things need to stick together and
here he says some uh some things that
not only are you know in general
misogynistic but
um weird for his own time right when he
has access to plays that have incredible
female characters like Sophocles
Antigone or he talks later about
euripides Medea and we can think of many
others as well and he tells us that
um you know there's courage of character
but it's inappropriate it doesn't
harmonize well for a woman to be
courageous or or clever Danae in this
way and you know you ask yourself when
you see that
how do you actually look at some of
these plays and come up with something
like that but that's that's a side note
that has more to do with Aristotle's
quirkiness about this the third thing is
uh what he calls
tohomoyo and likeness is how we
translate her similarity right and he
tells us uh here just that uh you know
this is distinct from goodness and being
appropriate and then he doesn't actually
tell us anything more at that point and
interestingly there's a gloss in this
translation by one of the by the
translator that says well that means
being like us but I'm not sure that
that's actually the case because of what
he's going to say a little bit later on
about likenesses which we'll get to in a
moment then the fourth thing is
consistency
right or to home alone and the opposite
of this
is the word that we get
anomalous from right or anomaly and this
is quite interesting what he has to say
here
so it tells us
um even if the subject represented is
someone inconsistent and such character
is presupposed he should still be
consistently inconsistent right so the
character needs to whatever it is
whatever qualities they have right the
Topo they need to be displaying these
consistently through the play or you
don't have character you get
inconsistency that doesn't make sense uh
he gives a few examples here saying um
you know Menelaus in the arrestes is
showing
um you know a kind of bad character
ponor yes
um you know
Odysseus is durge and skila the speech
of menelapy of inconsistency right so
these are these are characters where
things don't really match and so it's a
less successful portrayal so these are
the things that he thinks need to be in
there for a tragedy and then finally the
last thing that he says that's really
quite interesting and this harmonizes
with some other things that he says
about you know are you trying to do a
realistic portrayal of people no this
isn't history this is this is poetry
so he says The Poets should imitate good
portrait painters
interestingly enough what we have here
is mimesis at a higher level poets
tragedians are nomadic artists as our
portrait painters and the Very word for
imitate there or emulate in some of the
translations guess what it is
right so they are supposed to engage not
only in their own mimesis but also
imitate good portrait painters how so
well what a good portrait painters do he
says they render personal appearance
right the literally the edian morphine
morphe is like the shape the outline the
form we say of an object in this case a
person show the actual person in their
particularity to attain idiom
um and then he goes on and says
homoyus poyutes
so this is uh producing likenesses and
enhancing people's Beauty so the
likenesses that they're engaging in are
a little bit nicer than what the actual
person looks like so maybe they don't
put the big you know wart that is on
somebody's forehead or they're they you
know they make their nose a little bit
smaller a little bit bigger they instead
of painting them with dull dead eyes
they put a little Sparkle in their eyes
right so we should do this if we're
writing tragedy
similarly in how we portray the
characters now interestingly enough he
doesn't use an example from actual
tragedy he uses the example from Homer
which is epic poetry of Achilles and
what is Achilles Like I mean he talks
about when we're representing people who
are irascible right and uh also prone to
to fighting
right people who get riled up and worked
up right away he says that
um we should show them with other
character traits make them nonetheless d
decent people at the a case right and
what is the prime example here
agathon we make Achilles a good guy even
though he is a paradigm or an example
paradigma of
um we could actually translate this as
wickedness if you wanted to scale the
rote right but here it's being
translated as harshness Achilles is a
tough guy and he he gets angry and he
kills people right at the very beginning
of the Iliad he's debating about whether
he's going to draw his sword and kill
Agamemnon the leader of all of the hosts
at Troy and he chooses not to and Athena
helps confirm him in this and there's
you know a portrayal of him as a a good
guy a decent guy just having to put up
with these jerk uh you know colleagues
we could say and and rulers so you know
how would we do this in tragedy we have
a character perhaps somebody that we
know something about perhaps one that
we've made stuff up about you know we
try to portray them as as generally
being good they may have some character
traits some habits some motivations that
aren't completely good or could even be
bad
depending on how we look at them but we
try to you know emphasize the good parts
now this doesn't hold for all the
characters obviously this holds for the
characters that we are particularly
interested in as the protagonists for
antagonists or just run-of-the-mill
people
this doesn't actually hold but they have
characters that are displayed as well so
character absolutely Central to
Aristotle's understanding of what Greek
tragedy is and how it is supposed to
work